1 is underway in Gaza.
No,
the Great Replacement is real,
It depends on what we call Grand Replacement.
Innovation is open to the planet.
Yes,
Europe must deliver weapons to Israel.
Republicans and recapture are almost inevitable.
No, if you want peace,
prepare for war.
Of course.
The climate challenge is the biggest European issue,
one of the biggest issues.
Islamism is the greatest threat to Europe,
one of the biggest threats.
We need 1 European defense army.
No,
Catholicism should be revalued in Europe
as the root of Europe.
Yes.
If the Republicans didn't exist,
I will probably be at Reconquest.
But Republicans do exist.
I voted against the ban on cars
thermal systems in the European Parliament.
Yes,
France needs immigration.
No,
Valerie Ayée is on the left.
Yes,
it is necessary to
deport all foreign criminals and offenders.
Yes,
I am a Gaulist.
Maliste is the only one who is really green.
Yes,
immigration stirs up community conflicts.
Jordan Bardella will win the European elections,
we'll see. There are
has neighborhoods in France where the Republic is no longer.
Yes,
I am proud to be Portuguese at
Angela Merkel's parties in the European Parliament.
Angela Merkel is no longer in politics today.
I support a liberal European Union,
It depends on what we call liberal.
But yes,
we need freedom today.
My party is out of step with my group
in the European Parliament,
right?